well we're in the adrenaline section  there's this knee knocking hour here and  i won't delay anymore to present the  award for the best actor  a very brilliant academy award-winning  actress of last year miss anne bancroft  the nominees for the best performance by  an actor are albert finney and tom jones  richard harris in this sporting life  rex harrison and cleopatra  paul newman in her  sidney poitier in lillies of the field  the winner is sydney portraying  because  it is a long journey  to this moment  i am  naturally indebted to  countless numbers of people  principally among whom are ralph nelson  james poe  william barrett  martin baum and of course the men of the  academy  for all of them  all i can say is a very special thank  you